being smothered by a piece of paper
really puts your whole life into
perspective today we're gonna try emoji
face mask I don't know if there's
anything special about them aside from
the fact that they have emoji I don't
think that makes them pretty special
make my face into emoji please oh the
love mass you're like definitely cooler
than me so usually not even I always
make this face
it looks like the angry face I got the
angry face though piss off huh I like
the packaging very sleek it's just
screaming at me I love it it smells like
rose water let's just squirt it across
the ticket all these masks so slimy it's
so cute oh that looks like you quite
after cleansing I haven't washed my face
in like 24 hours okay
too angry god the end I'm pretty sure
these has a little like side hands that
are like Oh or bad well what was
reaching for this hole I'm panicking
under here you look amazing
God we're so creepy oh my good boy scary
a Homer Simpson V for Vendetta that's
what I look like right now
need to do this with friends and eyes
you're just a weird eye we look like two
nightmares speak for yourself
rude this is a nerdy surprise person
yeah I feel like we could rob a bank
like this we gotta wait 10 minutes so
we're gonna stroll around the office and
surprise our friends put some smiles on
their faces man this is terrifying
contact look at me
love me oh no okay this is the trustee
unless Gary yeah
what's wrong here look ten minutes later
kind of take it off you look happy
and your skin looks happy oh good it's
like I ain't want to take it off though
you look do here mm-hmm so yeah I wasn't
very refreshing it didn't look so hot
but it feels great now so I guess it's
all worth in the end I'm gonna put it
back on that all right it's having to
work for the rest of the day it's all it
looks like are it really looks like
you're melting Moltar my face does no
matter I feel refreshed
[Music]